so this scene was called clubhouse
forgery
we were looking for a way to reveal who
22 was
without her having to say anything and
so we came up with this idea
of 22's clubhouse it was her sort of
little private
hideaway space and the cool thing about
the scene
was that it gave us this opportunity to
show her character rather than talk
about it
for so who hates earth you sure have a
lot of earth in here
you know what's not in here people now
do you want my help or not
what are you doing making an earth pass
duh but we've got to make sure it's made
up of things tied to your personality
like a real pass now stop talking let's
see
you're into music you're kind of
old and raggedy hmm you're obviously a
nerd
there
oh almost forgot one egg
what's the egg for binding agent
[Music]
[Music]
utterly perfect
hey not bad this could work
well it was real it wasn't it was
theoretical
yeah i'm not gonna miss you see you
[Music]
yes yes
[Music]
no no no no no no
oh hey oh come on
you again hey i don't want to be stuck
with you either so unless you got
another bunk in that clubhouse of yours
okay okay i i've seen this goofy dude on
the astral plane i think he's from earth
come on follow me
but after this i'm out of ideas this is
really cutting into my me time
you